[Music]
that was an errand ladies and gentlemen
my fellow fiber the Home Council
colleagues and our board members our
first time a conference attendees and
those of you that come and join us every
single year our fiber-to-the-home
council members and most importantly our
sponsors without whom this event could
not happen welcome to Amsterdam those of
you that don't know me my name is Ronan
Kelly and I'm the president of the fiber
to the home council Europe those of you
that do know me know that I spend most
of my time throughout the year traveling
all over the world where I'm very
fortunate to get a lot of fantastic
cities but I have to be honest with you
of all the cities that I get to see
Amsterdam is right up there amongst my
favorites it's a city with so many
individual but uniquely Dutch buildings
a city with fantastic character while
you're here at our conference I'd highly
encourage each and every one of you to
take some time and get out and see the
city you're going to be greeted by a
city with so many friendly bars and
restaurants a city that has quite a
unique collection of museums a city that
very much has a special approach to
public transport you'll see that with
the canals you'll see it with the tens
of thousands of bicycles flying around
the place really quickly and you'll also
see the trams weaving their way through
the city which reminds me I do have a
word of caution for each of you when you
do go out and take in the city and again
I highly recommend that you do you see
some joker thought it would be a really
good idea to take the warning bell that
they use on the bicycles that's sort of
ding ding ding ding that you hear around
the place
this joker thought it'd be a really
clever idea to take that same Bell and
use it on the trams so you need to be
very careful out there the next time
when you're walking through the city and
you hear that ding ding ding ding ding
ding don't just assume
it's a harmless bicycle coming your
direction many a tourists over the years
is being caught out by that many of you
in the room who I know have been caught
out by that over the years so with that
cautionary note I'd once again like to
welcome each and every one of you to
Amsterdam and in particular
welcome to the 2019 fiber-to-the-home
conference I'd like to kick things off
with a question don't worry I don't need
you to raise your hand or shout out the
answers here I just want to give it you
to give consideration to it and that
question is how many of you have noticed
a change in the focus of
fiber-to-the-home council Europe
recently a change in our messaging a
change in what we're communicating you
see as the president of the
fiber-to-the-home council Europe over
the last three years I've stood in front
of many of you and I've encouraged you
to do whatever you can to preserve the
then proposed wording in the draft
European electronic communications code
that wording that would underpin the
regulatory environment for our entire
industry that wording that had such a
strong emphasis on full fiber that
wording that would ensure every European
citizen could avail of a full fiber
connection the wording that would drive
the future success and ultimately secure
the future livelihoods of so many of us
in the room today well I'm delighted to
have the opportunity to say
congratulations well done to all of you
because as of December last year the new
electronic communications code came into
force and it's currently on a transition
period over the next two years across
the EU member states so you see the
focus of the fiber to the helm council
Europe has changed it has evolved the
new targets have been identified for the
council and work has already begun on
those targets today as the president of
the fiber-to-the-home Council Europe I'd
like to talk to you about three of the
key focus areas the
the council is looking towards as part
of their future strategy the first is we
have copper networks that we need to
switch off second we must remember that
one gigabit per second is not the
endgame for gigabit societies and third
that vision of 5g we all know the vision
tens of millions of connected devices
latency that's comparable with fiber
error rates that are similar to fiber
and most importantly gigabits to
everybody that vision of 5g will remain
just at only a vision if we don't take
serious action and really start to ramp
off the massive fiber densification
that's going to be needed we need to be
careful about convent continued
investment in network infrastructures
that are barely up to the task of
gigabit society's needs because
continued investment in those
infrastructures is only going to serve
to delay Europe's transition to becoming
a leader on the global stage of gigabit
societies
governments must do whatever they can to
enforce the guidelines that have been
defined within the code they must
embrace the definitions around very high
capacity networks operators operators
need to begin laying down their plans
for copper switch off and the consumers
that includes all of you in the room
today the consumers must do their bit
they must use their spending power to
reward those operators that are willing
to make the investment and bring fiber
to those consumers let's reflect a
little bit there's no question that the
copper infrastructures throughout the
world have played an admirable role in
the global communication networks
without these extensive copper networks
many of which were built over a hundred
years
ago there would have been no early
internet no modems singing out there
handshakes no parents screaming up the
stairs at their teenagers to get off the
internet because they want to call your
granny I know many of you in the
audience were like me you were one of
those teenagers and your parents were
shouting up at you as we explored the
early internet with our Netscape
Navigator browsers on Windows 95 I'm
sure you all remember it it's quite
remarkable when you think about what the
smartest engineers in the world were
able to squeeze out of those copper
pairs first it was kilobits per second
then it was megabits per second and now
even with the right conditions you can
squeeze a gigabit out of those copper
lines but do you know what it's time to
stop squeezing because for society to
evolve for Europe to take the next big
leap and really take a leadership role
in both gigabit societies but also in
the emergence of 5g we must give up this
addiction to copper because this
addiction it's not good for Europe in
the long term it's not good for any of
us in the room here today but most
specifically for our children who have
to go out and compete in a world where
digital supremacy is all that matters
it's not good for our children out of
curiosity and this time I would like you
to see to raise your hand just so I can
get a feel for the awareness of this how
many of you in the audience have heard
of Project Faro very small percentage
about 1% or thereabouts as I mentioned
one of the future focuses for the
fiber-to-the-home council Europe is
around lobbying to try and accelerate
copper switch-off and as part of my role
when I travel around the world and I get
to speak with operators all over the
world it's always an enjoyable
conversation to talk to them about the
transition towards full fiber networks
everybody loves that part of the
conversation however an inevitable part
of that conversation then is when
move towards full fiber let's start to
talk about copper switch off and as you
can imagine that's quite in the mode of
topic that's worn but typically I'm
presented with a very long list of
reasons as to why this will never happen
the only list I ever get every year
that's longer than that is my kids
Christmas list so you know it's it's
quite a long list of excuses well for me
project farro is proof that this can
happen the copper switch off can be a
reality because with project farro what
we see is one of the operators in Europe
is focused on turning off one copper
exchange per day over the next three
years you see the numbers on the screen
behind me those numbers quantify the
volume of exchanges that are going to be
turned off every year now this is not
the work of some small niche operator
this is not a small project this is the
work of telefónica Spain a Tier one
operator in one of Europe's largest
markets now surely if telefónica Spain
this is telefónica remember who over the
last decade has had a lot of financial
challenges on their hands we yet they've
been able to drive this momentum and
move towards this ultimate target of a
pure fiber society if they can do this
what's stopping the other operators
across Europe doing the same and if they
lack the will they lack the vision to
pursue this goal then we need the
governments across Europe to intervene
we need them to use their regulatory
powers to encourage them or beat them
whichever it takes to drive in that
direction the governments must intervene
in support of this the fiber-to-the-home
Council Europe have kicked off their
latest study which is a migration to
fiber and copper switch off and for
those of you that are interested in that
Wieck consult which is our partner
that's driving that study we'll be
presenting some of the early findings on
where Europe is out on that front
during keynote session for later today
I'm sure many of you have noticed a
shift in the power across the globe over
the last decade with regard to which of
the largest companies in the world are
accumulating critical mass and becoming
the most powerful companies in the world
and it used to be a case that the oil
companies and the big engineering
companies companies like Exxon companies
like GE they used to be the ones that
largest companies in the world the
companies that countries would court to
try and get them to set off in their
regions but over the last decade that
has really transitioned now where we now
have a long long list of digital
technology companies that have
completely surpassed all of the
traditional companies and this has not
been lost on governments throughout the
world because the government's have come
to recognize that they want their
country to serve as the birthplace of
the next Google or the next Amazon or
the next Facebook that they need to
transition their societies to becoming
digital societies to becoming gigabit
societies but we need to be wary as part
of that we need to be wary of that
promise of gigabit society that's being
crafted by governments by industry by
academia throughout the world that that
promise does not become compromised it
doesn't become compromised by network
infrastructures that are barely up to
the task of meeting the needs of a
gigabit society we must push back on
wasteful investments that result in
networks that can barely make it over
the start line of gigabit society
consumers must be willing to say no to
inferior broadband offerings consumers
must be willing to demand a full fiber
connection only when they do that will
we be able to in the future connect our
homes our businesses connect to our
families
at tens of gigabits per second hundreds
of gigabits per second even terabits per
second only when we do that the true
potential of the vision of gigabit
society will be realized now as we
strive to try and secure access to full
fiber and really drive for this superior
form of connectivity we must be wary of
those that would seek to take advantage
of us as in all areas within society
they're those that try to pawn off
inferior product offerings as being the
real thing I find it fascinating that
the Advertising Standards Authority and
the local authorities are so quick to
clamp down on those that are selling
counterfeit goods whether it's in retail
stores or in markets etc well yet they
allow large scale corporations operators
across Europe continue to sell products
that masquerade as full fiber products
when quite clearly they're deficient on
so many different fronts I wonder how
many people we have in the audience
today from beric or from the national
regulators or even from the Advertising
Standards authorities don't worry I'm
not gonna call you out but it will ask
you to consider this question how is the
fake Rolex or the Louis Vuitton handbag
that sold on a market stall are sold
online how is that any different from
the fake fiber products that are being
sold across Europe today and sold every
day of the week the actions of those
operators that are selling those
misleading products though their actions
are misleading consumers who can't be
expected to know any better remember
were the 1% of the population here all
their technical oriented people the
other 99% can't decipher what's real
fiber and what's fake farmer their
actions are damaging the brand of fiber
their actions are damaging our brand the
brand that many of us in the room here
depend on for our livelihoods barek you
have a duty of care to the fiber
industry
to take action and to protect that fiber
brand to protect those fiber networks
and their reputations those same fiber
networks that are costing tens of
billions of euros to build if Europe is
to secure a place at the leadership
table of gigabit societies you need to
do your job you need to take action you
need to protect that fiber brand let's
talk about 5g the answer to all of
society's problems or was that wine just
mix those two up I find it very humorous
increasingly humorous now that we
consistently hear this question mark
about should you invest in fiber
networks because 5g is gonna replace all
of the fixed infrastructure it was
interesting Matthieu hair I don't know
if many of you saw the announcement
Matthew just launched his new fiber
company in the UK zoom and I was
watching some of the feedback he was
getting on LinkedIn during the week and
even during the week he was asked that's
very specific question by a couple of
people matthew is this a sensible thing
to get back into building fiber when 5g
is gonna replace your infrastructure and
I think this is hilarious I do if we
were to get to the point where we were
to stop inventing right here now invent
no new stuff no new connected things no
more immersive experiences no more
increases in the resolution of our
screens etc and really stop and freeze
at this point in time then maybe maybe
5g could have a fairly significant role
in replacing the fixed infrastructure
but the reality is were not going to
stop inventing right here right at this
moment in time the pace of innovation
throughout the world has never been
faster in the entire history of mankind
now gas wash what direction do we think
that pace is going in is it getting
faster again or is it starting to slow
down who thinks who thinks it's getting
faster let's see a show of hands
there we go exactly all right the pace
of innovation is getting only getting
faster I've said it to so many of you
over the years when I've spoke
at various different conferences the
bandwidth always precedes the
applications it makes for a really bad
business model to develop applications
that have bandwidth needs that are not
available in the market you can't sell
your product the bandwidth always
precedes the applications we recognize
that as society transitions beyond a
hundred meg and the new gigabit
societies really do begin to emerge we
will see the applications evolving and
developing to take advantage of that
additional capacity we recognize that
there will be some that 5g will
represent a viable alternative to a
fixed broadband connection and for
various different reasons quite often
for a lot of people that's they don't
want to be in a contract or they're
moving how soon or they will just want
mobility etc just like what we have with
4G with the higher capacity and the
lower latency of 5g we'll probably see a
slightly bigger portion of the market
that that fits their needs but remember
this 5g as an offering as an alternative
to fixed broadband in a gigabit society
will not be viable without that society
first becoming a fiber society let me
explain why on the chart behind me we
see the spectrum that is used by the
various different technologies for
delivery of data over the wireless
interfaces and if we look at 4G 4G
operates down around the megahertz end
of the spectrum into the low gigahertz
and we know from our 4G networks from
the cells we can get a couple of hundred
Meg that's shared between users and you
know we certainly get a good mobility
experience versus what we used to get on
3G we also get a small proportion of
society that use that as their primary
broadband connection as well but in
order for Ford or in order for cellular
to deliver that gigabit experience they
have to move up to the much higher end
of the frequency spectrum they have to
move up into what we call the millimeter
wave event or millimeter wave end of the
spectrum hope around the 60 70 80
gigahertz range of the spectrum if they
really want to deliver
services that will compete with fixed
infrastructure and they can do that you
can actually achieve those rates but
there's a little bit of a catch and that
catch is as the frequency increases as
the frequency increases the range that
we can send that signal decreases quite
substantially allow me to illustrate
this on the screen behind me we have
what we refer to in the industry for
those that are not familiar with it it's
a heat map and what that heat map shows
is the propagation of a radio signal
away from the base station and it shows
how the signal gets weaker as it
reverses away so the red dot in the
center there is where the base station
is and we can see the red in fairs that
it's a hot signal that's a really strong
signal and then it slowly but surely
gets cooler as it moves away from the
base station so it gets weaker to the
point where it's not usable and in this
scenario that we see on the screen here
the frequency that's used here is five
gigahertz now five gigahertz mostly some
of you in the audience may not realize
this but we use five gigahertz every day
of the week a lot of our Wi-Fi
connections in our home now run on five
gigahertz and we know that a five
gigahertz we can get a couple of hundred
megabits per second through and you know
it's a reasonable experience however if
we want to move things on to full
gigabit that's where we've really got to
move up to the other end of the
millimeter wave spectrum that's where
we've got to get up to the 60 70 and 80
gig and what you see with that is the
coverage that you can achieve at 60 gig
becomes much much smaller so this is the
same map overlaid and what you're seeing
is the coverage falls down to somewhere
between 50 and 75 meters either side of
the base station where you've got clear
visibility of the antenna what we say in
the industry is clear line-of-sight so
you can imagine if you want to achieve
the same level of coverage you've got to
roll out many many many more base
stations and if we think about the
implications for this for some of
Europe's larger societies this is going
to result in millions of small cells
having to be deployed
if 5g is really going to go toe-to-toe
with the fixed fiber infrastructures to
try and compete for that broad fixed
broadband business
so we said it last year on stage without
full fibre across Europe not vision of
5g being an alternative for the fixed
broadband infrastructure will never
become a reality
I hope it's becoming a little bit
clearer now as to why that is
now this massive densification that's
going to be needed if you picture the
amount of fiber backhauls that are gonna
have to be built in order to connect all
of those small cells back on to the
infrastructure it's going to be quite
substantial and some might jump to the
conclusion very quickly that that's
going to result in a massive cost
overrun and you know what you'd be
absolutely right if you don't take care
and plan things correctly on the screen
behind me you get a little bit of
insight into one of the studies that the
fibre of the home council Europe kicked
off last year and that study focused on
the cost of building out 5g
infrastructures and whether you could
use convergence with the fixed fibre
infrastructures to reduce that cost and
we asked our partner comms off to take
three models one and ultra-dense you
know downtown high-density city area one
an urban area and then one a rural area
and to come up with a model that showed
the cost of connecting everybody in
those three locations to gigabit
connectivity on full fibre then
separately come up with a model to
connect those same citizens to gigabit
connectivity but over 5g compared the
cost of those two separate network
infrastructures and then come up with a
third model that creates a network that
was designed from the get-go to cover
the needs of both the fixed broadband
consumers but also the 5g consumers and
all I can say is the cost savings are
nothing short of astronomical I'm not
gonna steal the thunder from keynote
session number one today hence I've
masked out the actual number there the
bar chart that's behind it but it will
say this if any of you in the audience
today still think that 5g and
fiber-to-the-home are unrelated you need
to go and listen to those findings
if any of you in the audience are
planning on building out your 5g
networks you also need to go and listen
to those findings because it's critical
there's massive savings to be hard when
you take into account the synergies the
synergies and the cables and the docks
the synergies in the active network
elements the synergies in the management
and orchestration systems those savings
are huge and for any of you that are
planning out your designing now your
large-scale fiber rollouts you also need
to go and listen to those findings
because there's a huge opportunity there
on tops that you can make your network
as you build it and design it to be
relevant to those that are planning to
deploy 5g I mentioned earlier that the
code since we all gathered here last
year the code is now from a policy and
regulation point of view being adopted
within Europe and we very much applaud
that also we're very confident now with
the current definitions around very high
capacity networks that the implications
of that from a fiber network build are
going to be huge we expect to see a
massive increase in the number of fiber
networks being built over Europe across
the next decade we do also recognize
from the code that they've drawn
attention to the need for different
business models in order to really drive
fiber propagation across Europe we've
got mixed environments we've got urban
suburban we've got rural and there's
different business models needed for
each of those in particular we see
within the code they draw attention to
the importance of wholesale only
business models and we've seen directly
the impact that they can have in
catalyzing a market to change we've seen
it in the Italian market we've seen it
in the UK market we've even seen it in
my own home market in Ireland when new
operators come in that operate in a
wholesale only capacity operators like
open fiber operators like open reach are
not open each City fiber apology's
operators like City fiber operators like
sciro it can have a huge impact in
catalyzing change particularly among
some of those operators that just
previously mentioned
it can have a huge impact in catalyzing
change amongst the incumbent operators
and that's critically important because
that drives the investment we've also
seen the impact that when you get the
regulatory environment just right and
hats off to Ofcom in the UK market under
sharon white we've really seen that when
the investors have the confidence to be
able to pump funding into the market
that the impact is huge
we see some of the existing fiber
operators they're like hyper optic
etcetera really exploding their plans to
build things out we see new entrants
like community Fiber ramping up their
deployments we see smaller players
coming into the market like truly etc
and as I mentioned earlier we've even
seen people that have enjoyed a
successful exit out of the fiber
industry come back in for more with the
likes of Matthew hare and zoom etc is
starting off their new venture for
building out fiber this is all fantastic
progress and this week we'll share the
results of the latest fiber to the home
council partner ama and within those
results you'll see that over 36% of
european households now can only gain
access to a full fiber connection you'll
also see that the take rates now are in
excess of 40% which is a real
achievement it's a good vote of
confidence that consumers are
recognizing the value of full fiber
connectivity but we must be cautious we
must not accept solutions that come from
Europe come from the regulator's come
from the operators even that result in
digital divide
we must not be willing to allow portions
of their society to avail of very high
capacity networks and all the spoils
that that brings while other portions of
her society remain having to suffer on
with a second-class broadband experience
and continue on to be Europe's digitally
impoverished remember the services that
come in the future over very high
capacity networks they're not nice to
have they're a must-have for every
single European citizen normally our
conference is always traditionally a
celebration of all things related to
full fiber but unfortunately this year
we've got some sad news to share since
we last gathered to celebrate everything
about fiber
one of the founding fathers of
fiber-optic transmission professor Sir
Charles Kao passed away
Professor Charles Kao who are our very
own gimme fiber day was created in
recognition of his birthday on November
4th every year he leaves an outstanding
legacy a legacy I'm certain that even in
his wildest dreams he could not have
imagined reflect if you will for a
second
the world that we live in today how we
communicate how we're entertained
how we work now imagine that world if we
didn't have all the inventions that came
as a result of Professor cares seminal
work who would be completely different
I'm very proud today to be able to share
with you the professor cow's legacy will
not be forgotten because starting this
year and every year going forward the
fiber-to-the-home council Europe will
have an annual award acknowledging the
efforts of an individual on a global
basis that has really taken up the
mantle and moved the ball forward with
regard to bringing full fibre to all
citizens and I'm also delighted to
announce that we've received the full
support from Professor cows widow and
his children to name - award after his
legacy and for that we applaud them
[Applause]
suffice to say the inaugural Charles Kao
award will be awarded tomorrow at 3 p.m.
so it highly encourage you all to attend
that to see who the first-ever winner of
that prestigious prize is before we wrap
up I'd like to ask you one last question
and again I don't need you to shout out
the answer or raise your hands on this
but I would like you to consider it and
that is when we all leave the conference
this week what is it are you are going
to do to advance the cause of full fibre
for all European citizens I'd ask you to
consider two possibilities in your
answer for that the first is when you
get home we must go online we must
search out those operators that offer
full fiber connectivity and we must sign
up for the service and if there isn't an
operator in our neighbourhood that can
offer full fibre we must register our
interest with those that are seeking
expressions of interest so they know
where to target because remember if we
in the industry whose livelihoods depend
on fiber-optic connectivity if we can't
show leadership and take on connections
ourselves what hope do we have of the
rest of the industry secondly I'd ask us
to use our voices collectively to call
out those fakes use our social media
channels to draw attention to fake fiber
advertising when we say it or better
again bring it to the attention of the
national advertising austerities it's
only when we use our voices collectively
together that we can stomp out those
parasites that live off the lifeblood of
our fiber brand so to reflect firstly
one gigabit per second is not the end
game for gigabit society it is only the
beginning and we must be wary of any
solutions that are being proposed to
barely make the grade for that second we
must use our voice to call out those
fakes and not allow our fiber brand to
be hijacked remember without full fiber
that vision of 5g is going to stage your
stache a vision and third local
governments must embrace the guidelines
that are within the code
they must embrace the definitions of
very high capacity networks and drive
their countries to implement them drive
their countries towards digital
leadership we the people we must embrace
those fiber services when they become
available to us we must reward those
operators that are willing to make the
investments to bring that fiber to us
and the operators just like telefónica
have just like Jersey telecom have and
you'll see if you sit in on keynote
session number four there's a lot of
other operators have all also as well
they must embark on their plans to start
organizing for copper switch off
collectively we almost try and do
whatever we can to ensure that Europe
has the best digital infrastructure in
the world so that when our children go
out and have to compete on that digital
stage that they can compete from a
position of power so with that I'd like
to once again welcome you all Tom Sadam
welcome you to the 2019
fiber-to-the-home conference one final
reminder please watch out for those
traumas when you're in the city thank
you